merci d'être avec nous parce qu'elle
savait le délire c'est moi qui vous
remercie pour cette première demi-heure
vous êtes élue du Val-de-Marne donc du
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste on va évidemment parler de la
réforme des retraites on va parler de la
mobilisation dans quelques instants mais
d'abord ce qui s'est passé hier à
l'Assemblée nationale et ce tweet de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui a mis le feu au
poudres incompréhensible retrait des
amendements du Parti communiste pourquoi
se précipiter à l'article 7 hâte de se
faire battre comment vous réagissez à ce
tweet
hier c'est ce tweet dans l'émission
On est aujourd'hui il faut le remettre
dans un contexte
on est dans un dans un conflit un
conflit antidémocratique
le gouvernement il a choisi une
procédure et il a trouvé le 47,1 un
article quel jumeau du 49-3 il a
raccourci le débat parlementaire
donc il y a un moment donné chacun
pensait responsabilités les
gouvernements il a pris les siennes mais
là
ce tweet
communisme d'avoir retiré leurs amendes
après attendez on va faire on va
simplifier franchement
on fera pas on fera pas bah attends
retraite madame borne sur son projet de
rallonger deux ans le temps de travail
avec un tweet tout le monde le sait le
marketing politique peut pas faire un
rassemblement majoritaire je le dis avec
un peu de solennité
parce qu'il faut respecter l'engagement
de l'ensemble des organisations
syndicales la mobilisation des députés
de toute la gauche
donc vous voyez voilà pas de marketing
politique pas pas des faits comme ça qui
peut en plus créer des divisions faut
travailler sur le sujet et le sujet
c'est quoi et qui en crée juste c'est
majorités
reste depuis des semaines extrêmement
majoritaire opposé à à cette à cette
réforme voilà et on est devant un un
processus totalement anti-démocratique
c'est le gouvernement qui veut pas qu'on
discute de son projet de loi et pourquoi
pourquoi avoir choisi cette procédure
avec un projet de loi rattaché
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale
d'ailleurs il y aura des problèmes de
constitutionnalité quand on regarde
l'ensemble des articles qui sont qui
sont posés là mais décide de raccourcir
le débat pour pour gagner voilà pour
finir par quoi
de museler le Parlement j'ai un souvenir
rappelez-vous la loi de finances au sein
de la loi de finances on a débattu ici
au Sénat 49.3 on vient d'avoir 10 49-3
c'est à dire à chaque fois le
gouvernement asphyxie le travail
parlementaire et ce qui ce qui est aussi
émane de la société donc là il y a trois
choses à agréger
voilà trois choses à agréger la rue la
rue la rue
l'expression de ce qui est visible et
manifeste mais aussi ces femmes et ses
hommes qui qui peuvent pas toujours
manifester ce qui se passe dans les
entreprises avec les salaires et cette
mobilisation contre les retraites et ce
qui se passe dans l'hémicycle et puis
c'est pas fini croyez qu'on a peur de
qui par rapport à l'article 7 vous savez
les articles personne a peur dans les
parlementaires de gauche et mes
camarades communistes à l'Assemblée non
pas sont pas tétanisé ou voilà
Jean-Luc Mélenchon veut pas y arriver à
cette article satinant il aurait pas
fait ce tweet oui je sais pas je sais
pas je vois pas bien l'utilité de n'a
pas besoin de ça en ce moment enfin je
vous le dis ce qu'on a besoin c'est de
gagner comme on avait gagné en 1995 on
est dans des conditions différentes il
faut gagner cet objectif c'est une
réforme structurelle madame je vous le
dis hein c'est c'est deux ans de plus
une réforme du travail d'ailleurs c'est
par hasard vous avez vu avant on a eu
l'assurance chômage il y avait pas
besoin de la réformer on était
excédentaire de 4,1 milliard après la
loi retraite ils veulent nous faire la
loi immigration et la loi travail donc
voyez c'est une réforme structurelle
c'est un choix de société c'est un choix
de civilisation quel va être votre
stratégie ici au Sénat le texte arrive
au Sénat la semaine du 27 février que
vont faire les sénateurs communistes et
est-ce que vous allez avoir une
stratégie commune avec les autres
groupes de gauche allez 27 février
c'est la réunion de la commission des
affaires sociales le 28 donc cette
commission va examiner le rapport qui
est issu de l'Assemblée nationale après
nous allons commencer à débattre le 3
mars le 2
c'est Nous Deux tiens au fait vous avez
raison que je rate pas cette séance
quand même et après on a jusqu'au 12 et
après il y a les navettes avec
l'Assemblée le débat en gros va aller
jusqu'au 26 mars quelque part si on
prend toutes les procédures donc il y a
le temps d'ici là pour le gouvernement
alors là franchement c'est la formule
qu'on a depuis plusieurs semaines avoir
un esprit de responsabilité de retirer
cette réforme voilà c'est ça l'esprit de
responsabilité c'est de la retirer
est-ce que vous aussi vous allez déposer
des centaines d'amendements ou est-ce
que vous souhaitez que le débat au Sénat
aille jusqu'au bout des articles mais je
comprends pas
votre question elle est pertinente mais
comment vous dire comment demander à des
parlementaires de pas déposer des
abonnements
quand vous avez majoritairement
l’opinion publique et contre une réforme
quand vous avez une mobilisation
unitaire de l'ensemble des représentants
du personnel des syndicats
comment vous dire NON NON taisez-vous
donc il y aura des amendements il y aura
toutes les procédures auxquelles on peut
avoir recours pour faire entendre raison
à ce gouvernement donc d'émotions de
rejet émotion référendaire toutes les
possibilités qui sont offertes par notre
règlement voilà par notre règlement par
les les responsabilités qu'on les
parmentaires dont ça sera un débat
politique je vous dis par exemple si
vous me demandez un amendement si vous
me dites il y aura un amendement par
exemple pour qu'on la ligne les salaires
sur l'inflation je vous dis oui il y
aura entre autres il y aura et alors
c'est pas bien de dire que si on
augmentait les salaires comme
l'inflation qui est pas tout à fait à 7
ça fait 12 milliards
est-ce que vous avez suivi mon
raisonnement c'est déjà le déficit qu'on
nous annonce ça serait réglé
donc on peut pas nous dire ne déposez
pas cet amendement et il y en aura bien
d'autres
article 7 soit examiné parce que
visiblement il le sera pas à l'Assemblée
nationale attendez pour l'instant pour
l'instant il y a le débat à l'Assemblée
nationale
il va s'arrêter ce soir vous avez raison
donc moi je commande pas ce que je
commande ce qui est factuel vous voyez
ce qu'est la réalité donc je vais
attendre la fin de ce débat comme comme
tous les autres parlementaires mais il y
a le 7 mars aussi
parler de cette mobilisation ce soir
s'arrête l'Assemblée nationale après le
2 mars commence le Sénat le 7 mars il y
a une mobilisation qui est en train de
se préparer on va en parler mais juste
on va aller Aurillac dans quelques-uns
un mot sur la mobilisation d'hier
c'était la plus faible en termes de
nombre et de manifestants depuis le
début de ces journées de mobilisation
est-ce que il y a un essoufflement
écoutez il y a un peu moins de monde en
contestablement enfin après il faut
aussi comprendre je rencontrais l'autre
fois les les gaziers à Alfortville c'est
60 à 70 euros une journée de grève j'ai
rencontré des enseignantes dans ma ville
on n'est pas loin du 100 euros la
journée de grève
il faut quand même c'est pas si ça on
dirait que c'est enfin quand il y a 800
000 personnes qui lisent Harry Potter
ont dit que c'est un succès incroyable
donc vous voyez quand il y a un million
400 000 personnes qui manifestent encore
hier et ben moi je vous dis que c'est ça
serait vraiment incroyable et on va voir
comment s'est passé dans nos régions on
va où on retrouve pierre Renaud bonjour
Pierre merci beaucoup d'être avec nos
directeurs départementales de l'édition
du Cantal pour le journal La Montagne et
Pierre vous revenez ce matin dans vos
pages sur la mobilisation dans votre
département
oui bonjour Alors oui l'actu hier dans
le Cantal c'était deux choses c'était
d'abord l'annonce par le spécialiste des
médicaments microbiotiques bios
industries qui le leader mondial dans
son domaine dans l'investissement de 80
millions d'euros dans son site de RIAC
et la création de 200 ans 2004 c'était
aussi le cinquième round de mobilisation
contre la réforme de retraite alors
grosse baisse de fréquentation Aurillac
qui contient un million de
manifestations dans son cortège ce qui
était prévisible en cette période de
vacances scolaires dans notre zone et
avant la forte mobilisation attendue de
cette mars Aurillac où la
sous-préfecture de Saint-Flour comme une
grande majorité des villes moyennes
avait massivement manifesté depuis le 19
janvier que reflète d'après vous
monsieur le sénateur cette France des
petites et moyennes villes fortement
mobilisés depuis le début du mouvement
alors donc c'est
oui moi j'ai je trouve qu'il y a il y a
une mobilisation assez exceptionnelle
des petites et des moyennes villes
et qui est pas qui est pas traditionnel
là il y a il y a un mouvement de
mécontentement moi je pense qu'il y a
plusieurs choses qui s'agrègent très
sincèrement je pense que il y a beaucoup
de gens qui se contrôlés abandonnés il y
a un recul des services publics de
l'État aux côtés en termes de proximité
il y a les difficultés liées à
l'inflation il y a des il y a eu les
difficultés liées y compris la mobilité
enfin vous avez vu ce qui se passe ils
vont à la pompe les gens vous avez vu ce
qui se passe avec l'essence à deux euros
litres donc je pense qu'il y a voilà il
y a une exaspération et puis il y a une
volonté d'être respectée franchement
alors est-ce que c'est plus dans les
petites et moyennes villes que dans une
métropole bah je sais pas s'il faut
graduer je pense qu'il faut agréger ça
mais incontestablement il y a juste ce
que je ressens c'est qu'il y a un besoin
d'égalité d'être considéré à égalité sur
un certain nombre de droits fondamentaux
des droits communs vous voyez de de pas
être relégué et puis de l'autre côté
d'être respecté voilà je ressens ça que
que voilà leur vie soit respecté leur
travail soit respecté donc c'est pas
uniquement la réforme des retraites pour
vous c'est une agrégation de colère
c'est un sentiment de relégation
de la PQR mais peut-être qu'il va y
avoir le set le 8 le 9 ou le 10 mars
peut-être des des villes où les
commerçants vont prendre part en fermant
les commerces voyez je pense que il faut
enfin en tout cas voilà il y a une
manifestation très large il y a la
manifestation dite classique dans la rue
elle est très importante mais il faut
que d'autres formes il faut que des
commerçants il faut il faut être
d'autres formes de mobilisation
peut-être aussi dans les établissements
scolaires dans les universités etc
puisqu'on a beaucoup on parle beaucoup
des jeunes des jeunes des jeunes mais
enfin quand on voit allez dans le Cantal
et voir un jeune du Cantal vous lui
dites un jeune une solution
je crois pas qu'il va adhérer à ce mot
d'ordre de Gabriel Attal
on a beaucoup de solutions dans le
cancer de Monsieur sénateur c'est bien
ça
avec les gens du Cantal
j'ai trouvé un petit dicton qui est
marrant c'est le meilleur âme garde
toujours un coup de pied de mètre donc
ça veut dire dans le Cantal vous avez un
caractère bien trempé
et Pierre pierre vous avez un petit
éclairage musical à nous faire sur la
mobilisation d'hier
on va toujours parler de la retraite
mais on va en parler sous un angle plus
léger romain blanc qui est journaliste à
l'agence la montagne d'Aurillac c'est
intéressé à la à la playlist du
grévistes de la manifestation d'hier je
vais vous donner la tendance Aurillac la
CGT penche plutôt pour Damien Saez vous
le collective motivé alors que il faut
un fait pour HK et les saltimbanques
j'imagine que vous avez battu à 20 €
prise le pavé monsieur aussiateur à quoi
ressemble votre playlist et
si vous êtes de bonne humeur pour
commencer la journée du bon pied est-ce
que votre réponse pourrait se faire en
chantant c'est à vous
chanter c'est une catastrophe pour pour
les auditeurs de la publicité
c'est une catastrophe si je chante
vraiment par contre motivé j'aime bien
franchement motivé ça me va
voilà
je peux vous dire je pense que il faut
le prendre de manière pacifique mais
quand on dit ce soir je vous mets le feu
je pense que vis-à-vis de l'injustice
que cette réforme des retraites je pense
que beaucoup l'ont en tête ce soir on
vous met le feu voyez l'idée franchement
respectez-nous et arrêter de de de faire
cette réforme des retraites et du
travail enfin vous savez j'ai en tête un
il y a 9 % des gens qui meurent avant 60
ans Alors pas tous bien évidemment de
par leurs conditions de travail de par
leur pénibilité et voyez moi je veux
valeur humaine voyez cette valeur
humaine dans une dans toute réforme il
faut aller la chercher la valeur humaine
merci vous avez votre réponse mais pas
votre chanson du coup mais merci
[Musique]
pour chanter mais là ça me demande
vraiment beaucoup de préparation
monsieur
d'avoir été avec nous la une de la
montagne sur l'autre actualité dans le
Cantal vous l'avez dit bio investi 80
millions et crée 200 emplois merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous Pierre
Raynaud on va passer à l'actualité du
Sénat maintenant Pascal ça vole des lits
avec vous puisque mercredi le Sénat a
voté un texte pour sécuriser
l'approvisionnement des Français en
produits de grandes consommations n'en
parle tout de suite avec notre
journaliste parlementaire Mathias Arès
[Musique]
bonjour Mathias bonjour Oriane bonjour
monsieur le sénateur
dans cette émission bienvenue merci et
on va parler de ce qui s'est passé au
Sénat cette semaine le Sénat qui a donc
adopté mercredi en première lecture la
proposition de loi sur
l'approvisionnement des Français en
produits de grande consommation c'est
vrai Oriane mais c'est un texte remanier
qu'on t'adopter mercredi les sénateurs
première modification son nom le
rebaptisant proposition de loi tendante
à renforcer l'équilibre dans les
relations commerciales entre
fournisseurs et distributeurs ce que n'a
pas manqué de souligner le ministre de
l'Agriculture Marc féno en ouverture des
débats ce texte vise à un meilleur
équilibre des relations commerciales
mais il ne s'agit pas de monter les
distributeurs contre les industriels ou
l'inverse notre souveraineté alimentaire
et la sécurité de nos approvisionnements
sont des préoccupations partagées par
tous par tous les Français également il
faut le dire par l'ensemble des maillons
de notre chaîne alimentaire
parmi les mesures prises les sénateurs
ont donc prolongé de deux ans et non
trois comme le voulait l'Assemblée
nationale le dispositif SRP + 10
consistant à obliger les distributeurs à
réaliser une marge minimale de 10% sur
les produits alimentaires ils ont
toutefois apporté deux garde-fous un
exclure les fruits et légumes du
mécanisme la filière assurant qu'elle y
perdait deux une obligation annuelle
pour les distributeurs de rendre compte
de l'usage des marges réalisées parce
qu'elles symbole d'Élie ce mécanisme est
décrié par les associations de
consommateurs ils parlent d'un chèque en
blanc au distributeur pourquoi avoir
fait ce cadeau
d'abord on est sur un sujet extrêmement
important parce que bon il y a cette
inflation qui est autour de 6 7 on va
dire 7 pour nos pour nos auditeurs et
nos auditrices les chiffres sont
affolants 60% de plus la bouteille
d'huile
27% pour la farine 16% pour la volaille
mais
voyez on est sur certaines à travers
cette moyenne là on est sur une
inflation de l'alimentation qui est
catastrophique et c'est encore les mêmes
qui sont victimes de ça c'est les plus
modestes les plus précaires quoi alors
ce que je veux dire moi c'est qu'il faut
qu'on arrive à trouver évidemment une
négociation c'est évident entre
distributeurs en respectant de deux
familles bah les consommateurs il faut
arriver à faire baisser des prix quand
même qui deviennent inaccessibles du
point de vue de la consommation vous
savez 5 fruits 5 légumes
juste du point de vue de notre
alimentation impossible pour beaucoup de
gens et de l'autre côté il faut aussi
améliorer la rémunération des
producteurs donc il faut voilà la
question qu'il faut c'est faut arriver à
les tenir ce qui détiennent la grande
distribution il y a la question
d'intervenir il faut s'inviter dans leur
marge je m'excuse de le dire ça peut
paraître un peu intrusif mais la marge
des grandes des grands distributeurs il
faut un peu la réduire il faut être
moins avide vous voyez de profitabilité
il faut reconnaître le travail des
producteurs il faut qu'il soit pris en
mieux en pris en compte les agriculteurs
et de l'autre côté il y a les
consommateurs voilà faut trouver cet
équilibre et cet harmonie Mathias on va
continuer à parler de ce texte il y a
d'autres modifications qui ont été
apportées lesquelles absolument les gros
morceaux du texte touchait
principalement les professionnels du
secteur vous l'évoquez une mesure
importante jusqu'à présent les marques
de distributeur n'étaient pas concernés
par la sanctuarisation de la part pour
le monde agricole part sur laquelle les
distributeurs justement pouvaient rogner
les marges avec cette version du texte
ce ne sera plus le cas monsieur le
sénateur le Sénat font des pas
énormément d'espoir dans cette loi je
crois que votre groupe encore moins
est-ce que avec ces mesures le texte est
malgré tout un peu plus juste
écoutez je pense qu'il faut aller
beaucoup plus loin vous l'avez compris
dans mes propos je pense qu'il faut
qu'on ait une proposition plus
oui plus fort plus volontariste excusez
moi le dire vis-à-vis des grandes il
s'agit pas de mettre à plat les grands
distributeurs c'est qu'il réduisent
encore leur mage et qu'on soit au côté
je vous le dis des producteurs des
agriculteurs parce qu'après il y a la
question des circuits courts il y a la
qualité aussi de ce qu'on mange et là on
a un savoir-faire extraordinaire dans
notre pays de parler producteurs
agriculteurs et de l'autre côté il faut
regarder les produits de consommation
parce que là je vous donne c'est
vraiment des chiffres
bon franchement mais est-ce que là il y
a eu des lois il y a eu de loyer pour
équilibrer
vraiment très ouvert à l'ensemble des
régimes alimentaires que chacun souhaite
mais pour ceux qui veulent regarder le
bifteck haché il est à 25 30% on va
parler de l'inflation les distributeurs
et les agriculteurs et est-ce que malgré
les tentatives de rééquilibrer ses
relations les l'équilibre est encore
trop en faveur des distributeurs pour
vous ah pour moi oui
oui je le dis qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
pour nos agriculteurs alors on est à 8
jours d'ouverture du salon de
l'agriculture qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
pour nous poser sur la grande
distribution pour leur faire baisser les
marches
après je vais vous dire je sais pas si
c'est le sujet un sujet sur lequel je
vais travailler d'autres ils travaillent
je pense que vous voyez dans la dans la
crise de la société telle qu'elle est
avec toutes les difficultés qu'il y a
moi par exemple je veux travailler à une
sécurité sociale alimentaire
et forcément vous voyez c'est ça c'est
quelque chose de d'innovant de
créativité vous avez on a le débat là
sur les retraites on pourrait avoir le
débat plus globalement sur la sécurité
sociale je pense que cette question de
l'alimentation du début du processus de
départ qui est quand même la production
donc là on touche au producteurs jusqu'à
la diffusion moi je pense qu'il faut
aller une sécurité sociale de
l'alimentation qui sera un événement
extrêmement progressiste et prégnant
dans notre société donc face à ce
travail donc je pense qu'il faut qu'un
lac législatif qui pose cette question
d'une nouvelle sécurité sociale
alimentaire bah c'est s'assurer
vous savez il y a une charte de
l'environnement il y a plein de
mécanismes qu'on a mis en place sur des
enjeux très importants il y a encore
beaucoup de travail sur l'eau sur
l'environnement je pense que cette
question de l'alimentation il faut il y
a des entretiens qui se tiennent moi je
suis du Val-de-Marne donc je connais le
mine de Rungis il y a eu les entretiens
de Rungis il y a il y a un travail qui
s'opère mais voilà il faut revoir cette
question là pour
non pas les tatiser vous comprenez mais
pour que chaque produit de qualité à des
prix une alimentation de qualité et pour
tous et toutes voilà et justement on va
parler puisque vous parlez de
l'inflation et vous ne donnez
effectivement les chiffres mais il y a
des mesures qui touchent directement
portefeuille des Français Mathias
absolument parmi les mesures grand
public on retrouve celle qui visent à
limiter les pourcentages de réduction
sur un produit sur ce point c'est
quasiment la version de la commission
des affaires économiques du Sénat qui a
été adopté les fameux 34% maximum en
valeur vous savez pour le 2 + 1 de
l'alimentaire ils ont été élargis à tous
les produits de grande consommation en
particulier les DPH droguerie parfumerie
hygiène pour le coup c'est une mesure
qui ne va pas améliorer le pouvoir
d'achat des Français
qu'est-ce que je vous dise les produits
d'entretien premier prix ils ont
augmenté de 27,55%
, vous savez pour une famille modeste
le gel douche voyez tout les protections
que fait le quotidien de millions de
gens quand même vous imaginez je viens
ce matin sur votre plateau avec
enthousiasme et je me dis mais Pascal
enfin produit d'entretien
27,55%. les prodigènes
12,71% d'augmentation quelle femme quel
homme quel foyer a une telle
augmentation du point de vue de ses
revenus vous voyez le décalage qui
s'opère et sur des questions là
essentielles mais alors justement le
gouvernement travaille à un panier
anti-inflation sur une cinquantaine de
produits justement pour les rendre plus
accessibles des produits d'hygiène mais
pas seulement est-ce que c'est une bonne
idée faisons le panier ensemble
non mais franchement moi je vais vous
dire sur l'idée qu'un panier où on
protège réellement au moins 50 produits
si on construit ensemble donc avec les
associations avec ceux qui sont dans le
sur le terrain quoi vous voyez pas les
cabinets c'est pas les experts des
cabinets privés c'est pas les experts
des cabinets privés qui vont nous faire
le caddie des gens qui sont en
souffrance de leur 50 produits
nécessités faut être clair on est dans
un autre monde la faut aller au cœur
faut faire de la démocratie de terrain
il faut aller voir les gens les plus
modestes
enquêter il y a des associations il y a
des organismes aussi que choisir 60
millions de consommateurs
on peut pas ça serait irresponsable de
dire que c'est une mauvaise idée après
il faut aussi que tout le monde prenne
ses responsabilités vous le savez ici au
Sénat comme à l'Assemblée on a un débat
sur la TVA et l'impôt le plus injuste et
la TVA vous savez qu'elle est différente
suivant les produits voilà donc il faut
revoir ça il y a plein de choses à
revoir il y a même je vais vous dire
faudrait presque tout changer
on verra on va parler d'un autre sujet
où là aussi
j'ai changé des choses je remercie
maths à tout à l'heure
on parlera évidemment de la séance voilà
merci il y a d'autres prix qui
augmentent c'est le prix des péages les
péages des autoroutes qui ont augmenté
de 4,75 % au premier février est-ce que
vous demandez aux sociétés autoroutières
de faire un geste
alors c'est encore dans le c'est le
porte-monnaie des ménages les autoroutes
excusez-moi de cette image je viens de
parler de la TVA les pH c'est comme la
TVA
c'est à dire que
plus vous êtes modeste et moins vous
avez de revenus vous payez quand même le
même prix que l'autre qui a un très bon
revenu et tant mieux qu'il a un très bon
revenu c'est pareil les péages quand
vous passez vous payez le même prix et
là le fait que les autoroutes soient
privées et qu'elles étaient privatisées
leur laisse une totale liberté
d'augmenter les prix comme vous venez de
le faire alors avec un petit jeu sur les
petites portions d'autoroute on le fait
pas les grandes portions le fait
franchement
il faut prendre une mesure on arrive à
la fin on arrive à la fin des contrats
de concession tout le monde le sait vous
le savez que que le groupe communiste au
Sénat le propose il faut ronacialiser
les les autoroutes avant la fin des
contrats de concession non à la fin
sinon vous êtes dans l'illégalité donc
voilà il faut le faire à la fin mais il
faudrait déjà mais faut rester les
moyens de reprendre à sa charge la
gestion des autoroutes
il suffirait il faudrait déjà le dire
maintenant parce que ça se prépare vous
voyez ça se prépare faut être compétent
quand on veut voilà donc ça se prépare
et donc je vais vous le dire tout de
suite puisque ça rejoint le débat y
compris sur les déficits publics sur un
d'endettement quand même catastrophique
de la France je vais vous dire c'est 50
milliards de recettes pour l'État
donc on n'est pas seulement envoyé là
des dépensiers quand on dit ça et l'État
aura les moyens de mettre en place un
dispositif qui empêche que ça soit
encore les ménages qui fassent les frais
de leurs droits la mobilité là c'est la
double peine je vais vous dire vous avez
la peine à la pompe et vous avez la
peine la double peine après c'est au
péage avec la même injustice que la TVA
quel que soit vos retenues quelle que
soit votre situation vous payez plein
pot merci parce que c'est moi qui vous
remercie bonne journée merci bonne
journée à vous d'en 20 minutes dans le
clavier territoire on va parler de la
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites et des débats agités également
à l'Assemblée nationale ce sera à suivre
dans 20 minutes mais d'abord on va
parler d'un tout autre sujet on revient
sur les un nom de guerre en Ukraine avec
notre invité c'est Bertrand m'a dit qui
nous rejoint